you never got your piercings infected or
anything you did the right thing you did
the protocol I did the protocol you
didn't like stick your finger in your
butt and then put on your
I was like man I ran out of
it
[Music]
all right we got another super sad story
um a guy in San Diego County he's
chasing after his dog in the mountains
trying to catch his dog his dog jumps
into a pond the dude goes into the pond
after to try to grab the dog
homie has a little small cut on his arm
oh no he gets the bacteria fresh eating
the flesh
so soon after that he started developing
these blisters that they would ooze a
burning acid onto his skin Oh my God
it's gnarly so um he goes to the
hospital he tries to put like antibiotic
cream on it doesn't really help Ben Gay
he goes to the hospital and two days
later he's dead oh [__] is it that
septic shock or whatever the [__] or
the flesh-eating bacteria the thing
turns out he caught a flesh eating
bacteria it this particular bacteria has
a 30 survival rate and uh you can catch
it just from being in stagnant water
with an open wound yeah I heard that
like dudes be just having like a little
scratch that their cat did or whatever
yeah and then it's like trash juice
sewer juice Whatever Gets In yeah and
boom they're done that's what happened
to the um to the leader of the Midnight
Mission down here at downtown oh that's
right you told us about that he had like
a little cut on his leg and then he like
works with like the homeless people in
the area and he got a little something
in his leg and they it got affected they
had to chop it off that's why in boot
camp we only take showers with a dial
which is antibacterial soap and there's
inspections every night so every night
like the squad leader like you get your
whole Squad and everyone's standing like
this so you walk up and down you look to
see if there's like any Cuts if there
are any Cuts did they get worse and you
check nails and you check like the feet
and you look at the back like everyone's
butt naked and you go up and down did
you ever see a person did he lift your
balls and stuff too yeah cuts down there
you you
um I didn't see anybody
but you yeah you have to check because
you're either crawling all the time or
you might be going under barbed wire and
you just get like a little Nick that you
don't even know about yeah and then it
can turn into something you know damn
dude so scary I know pretty rough that
you just have no clue but yeah standing
stagnant water is that big of a risk
that [__] is gross some water looks bad
though yeah just look oh [__] that's why
is it looking like that toxic ooze yeah
so what have you swallowed it oh you're
probably gonna die oh I don't know would
that would that be different I'm not
sure like what is that because your
stomach acid's supposed to boil
everything or you could like expel it
yeah you have a chance of that but if
it's your bloodstream that's a different
Beast right because it goes straight
into your system your main lining it so
what happens there's no treatment for
flesh eating there's a chance of
fighting it if you get in early enough
yeah like everything else they're not
telling you this number one Secrets
Physicians hate oh what is it I love
this stuff lactobactille acids okay
that's basically Jaco dude you poor yako
probiotics is a true antibiotic dude
probiotics feeds the bacteria that's
per se
[Laughter]
feeds the gut bacteria yeah but that's
good bacteria and they they kill the bad
bacteria and it's pre-bio prebiotics
that feeds the bacteria oh really okay
and also too in like Western doctors and
[__] or like the Western hospitals it's
like they take so [__] long to figure
out what's happening with you anyway so
it's like this poor dude didn't have a
chance yo I would have peed on it and
poured uh yako on it already that's what
I'm saying none of you guys ever had a
wound get infected maybe uh I have I got
my tattoo infected right here just this
part because I told you not do that
either because he went to a backyard
tattoo artist why you do that yeah why
you do that man well I don't know but
the guy was like new so anyway the pop
the problem was it's where my joint is
so even though it's done and it's not
like cut or anything the more I move it
and when your skin is like dry and
cracked yeah it cracks and look at what
you do all day
once you get going you can't stop but
that's like the worst infection I ever
had though because it was like oozing
yeah I have I have such a negative
connotation with infection infected
wounds because the first time that ever
happened to me it was something dumb
like I had just scraped my knee at a
show and then the wounded my knee got
infected over the course of like three
days and I missed a very very important
uh important engagement really where we
were um for LMFAO we were invited to the
Playboy mansion and the theme was WWF
oh what were you gonna address I was the
only person I didn't get to go because
that because I had to be on meds that I
couldn't have lost oh no
forget if it was at the Playboy Mansion
if it was any party that was WWF theme
that would have been exactly yeah and so
like who would you gone at yeah yeah
what would you I didn't even I didn't
even think that far I was just so mad
just so sad and because also at the time
that that happened I'm known to like
never get hurt whatever and when it
happened everyone thought I was like
being over dramatic and faking it like
if you're known to never get hurt
shouldn't it be like if you got hurts
like oh It's gotta be really bad yeah
that's what I was trying to say I'm like
my whole leg is red because it started
at my knee and then it just turned my
whole leg red from like my shin to my
thighs
because I went to the like my dad who
was an X-ray tech I go to the hospital
they all the doctors there just hooked
me up and then I came in there and they
were like damn and then they like went
like uh that's not what you want to hear
yeah yeah yeah yeah they just like on
the spot just drain that [__] out
because it had all this like like pus
and water and stuff God I remember I got
my first infection like really early on
where like I didn't know what's
happening you know when you're a kid
like people always tell you gotta wash
it or you gotta put iodine or hydro
peroxide on it or rubbing alcohol but it
just hurts so much like that hurt more
than the injury so you would just hide
it yeah you know you'd be like let's say
you're playing with something like ow
and your mom's like what happened
nothing nothing nothing happened because
you don't want to pour alcohol It's
Gonna Hurt the Bactine and that orange
[__] yeah and then I remember like uh
inward kid you're [__] dirty as [__]
and like a few days later it's like my
hands like all like swollen or some [__]
like that and then I remember my mom's
like Oh it's [__] infected and then
you like you like squeeze it all his
[__] puss comes out you're like
so ever since then I was like as soon as
like I get a cut I take care of it with
yeah like alcohol or iodine or whatever
the [__] it gets so bad there's so many
gnarly accidents I have never had one in
my like later adults infections are no
joke man like you kind of just like like
it's not a big deal like it would never
happen to you and then when it does it's
so inconvenient mine was piercings oh
really I had it all on my cartilage and
I had like I look like cauliflower here
but I was like
earrings with a [__] ear
that was filled with Plus
and then I had to take it out and
squeeze it all out and then yeah
that's disgusting dude that's disgusting
yay
come on man I'm right here
it was only on one side yeah can you
imagine
[Laughter]
oh damn good thing you didn't affect
your hearing huh oh that's true I know
I've had I've had something and get
infected because of my piercing like
back here and it was it was so painful
and just like once it popped though I
was like oh thank goodness did you get a
pierced with a gun or like with a from a
guy from a backyard I've only had guns
was your ear all [__] up afterwards no
it wasn't from the god it wasn't from
the the day of the initial piercing it
was like you know how I like when your
ears close up and you try to like
re-pierce it like poke it back that's a
good idea and it scratches it and then I
didn't know and so it just got swollen I
was like oh did you wash your needle
first uh and put burn on it so when you
go go to a piercing place and they and
they pierce your ear and it ends up
getting infected is that your fault or
is that their fault it's your fault
actually really because you just keep it
clean yeah because they'll put out
they'll do what they're supposed to do
but when you go home you need to take
care of it everything you gotta maintain
it yeah I didn't know how to take care
of it at all you just left it I left it
with ear crust and everything I was a
freaking 13 year old oh yeah that's a
tough age I don't know what the [__] I
was doing with my body dude you never
got your piercings infected or anything
you did the right thing you did the
protocol I did the protocol you didn't
like stick your finger in your butt and
then put on your
I was like man I ran out of ointment
yeah
what about the stagnant Lakers make a
full out of me
and I strike players
no no yeah no getting infections in your
isn't it like common to get them in your
like gum or like oh yeah I had one in my
gum yeah yeah yeah really because I wear
these plastic retainers right that go on
and it just like covers everything right
and so you're supposed to clean it with
mouthwash right I don't know you're
supposed to do it every night but
sometimes like I'm like you know I'm
just gonna rinse it leave it there and
then I did that one day and then I went
to sleep with it woke up I was like oh
my gums are swell I'm like damn it I
should have just put it in mouthwash I
will buy you mouthwash I think our
mouths are cesspools hygienic things
it's supposed to be every day yeah I I
yeah I learned that the hard way yeah
he's like my contacts should I just
there we go
yeah dude I mean I watched my contest
like once a month
leave them in all day that's our JK PSA
take infection seriously clean you clean
your wounds don't jump into stagnant
water with open cuts and uh what else
our bodies are fragile man you gotta
take care of it yeah we're kind of we're
kind of whack I jump into Waters all the
time you look like you do
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign